allez quelques résultats pour conclure
cette édition du 7 8 oui les jeunes de
l'USB Guyancourt continuent de rêver ils
ont signé l'exploit majuscule de ce
week-end lors du sixième tour de Coupe
Gambardella on s'imposant face à mi sur
la petite la plus petite démarche sur le
score de d'un but à zéro ils sont donc
qualifiés pour les 64e de finale qui
auront lieu le 13 janvier prochain en
championnat chez les seniors avec le
froid certains terrains commencent à
être impraticable ce week-end plusieurs
matchs ont été reportés dont celui du FC
Versailles en DH qui devait se rendre
sur la pelouse de l'Entente Sannois
Saint-Gratien dans le Val-d'Oise et de
Trappes face à Saint-Leu mais sur le
terrain de l'Entente sportif parisienne
le S Guyancourt s'est imposé un but à
zéro et consolide sa place de leader
avec deux points d'avance sur le
deuxième Aubervilliers on continue un
petit bon de rugby peut-être oui du
rugby le PRC dont le coach était venu la
semaine dernière
expliquait un petit peu le bilan
mi-saison bah ça commence mal à la phase
allée pour le PRC du championnat de
fédéral 3 les plaisirs 3 se sont
inclinés sur la pelouse de Saint-Maur 17
à 10 les joueurs de Philippe bé
reviennent tout de même avec le point du
bonus défensif du Val-de-Marne et reste
3e de Fédérale 3 du basket féminin on
avait quitté l'équipe de Versailles le
chêne et Versailles sur une défaite leur
première défaite de la saison la semaine
dernière et bien les féminines de
l'entente de chêne et Versailles ce sont
vite relancés après leur faut pas les
joueuses de devine cobardić se sont
imposées sur le parquet de Rezé 56 à 53
avec 21.11 journée presque un bilan
parfait le LCV est toujours leader de
National 2 avec un point d'avance sur le
deuxième Calais et très rapidement les
Templiers d'Élancourt c'est du foot US
la saison n'a pas encore commencé non ça
n'a pas encore commencé hein mais c'est
là c'est la phase de reprise la phase de
préparation avec les matchs amicaux et
les Templiers d'Élancourt se sont
imposés ce week-end face à
Villebon-sur-Yvette sur un score assez
large 30 à 12 et le Vendée Globe se
poursuit tanguy de Lamotte le versaillé
est toujours en compétition notre
traditionnel point hebdomadaire sur
Tanguy un mois tout juste qu'ils sont
partis des Sables-d'Olonne dans cette
course autour du monde en solitaire et
sans escale le skipper Versailles
initiative cœur tanguy de Lamotte est
toujours que de peloton il pointe à la
douzième place est en train de passer à
l'heure où je vous parle le Cap de Bonne
Espérance mais il a connu quelques
ennuis mécaniques à cette nuit le point
de fixation avant de de son jeune écœur
qu'on voit à l'image c'est cassé
autrement dit c'est la pièce qui permet
de tendre la voix afin d'avoir de la
prise au vent et de gagner de la vitesse
petite réparation de fortune et selon
Tanguy cela fonctionne très bien et
c'est la deuxième fois que ça lui arrive
ce jour-là c'est un peu difficile
toujours en compétition on en reparlera
sans doute lundi prochain lors de la
prochaine page de sport merci Anthony on
quitte le sport juste pour parler cinéma
demain mardi à 21h Omar Sy revient dans
les Yvelines le comédien césarisé pour
son rôle dans intouchable et originaire
de Trappes vous le savez il sera de
passage pour présenter son nouveau film
de l'autre côté du périph une comédie
policière avant de découvrir le film
demain si vous allez à l'UGC mais aussi
de découvrir l'interview ou d'Omar Sy
des mercredis sur tvfils 78 voici la
bande-annonce de ce film de cette
comédie avec Laurent Lafitte
tu vas me faire griller regarde ta tête
tu pues le Picasso
moi si je me fonde dans le décor
criminel de Paris j'ai toujours été très
allé sur le terrain merde
c'est pas vrai c'est la fameuse affronte
les gars vous regardez pas la télé j'ai
dit plus aucun suivi sur le site merde
alors
Omar Sy qui revient donc sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
l'avant-première de ce film à 21h et
puis il sera mercredi sur cette antenne
sur antenne de tvfils 78 en interview Le
7 8 revient demain mardi direct à 18h
avec de nouveaux invités vous pouvez
revoir cette émission dès demain matin
en consultation libre sur notre site
Internet à vos commentaires sur les
réseaux sociaux excellente soirée